I'm agent mobius by the way
are you taking me somewhere to kill me no that's
where you just were i'm taking you someplace to
talk but i don't like to talk but you do like
to lie which you just did because we both know
you love to talk not keep talking how long
have you been here i don't know it's hard
to say you know time passes differently here
in the tva what does that mean you'll catch up
so you're part of the tva's
courageous and dedicated workforce
yes you were created by the timekeepers
to protect the sacred timeline correct
is that funny the idea that your
little club decides the fate of
trillions of people across all of
existence at the behest of three
space lizards yes it's funny it's
absurd i thought you didn't like to talk
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
loki trailer video they dropped a whole bunch of
new footage there's a bunch of easter eggs here so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to the
channel i'll be doing videos for all the episodes
it's going to start in a couple weeks so be sure
to subscribe to get everything we're also doing a
giveaway for disney plus memberships all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and just leave
all your predictions for the series on the video
as you can see with loki we're pushing more
into the concept of the multiverse with all
these alternate realities with him having to go
around and clean up all these alternate versions
of himself that seem like they're all meant to be
way worse than this new main version of loki who
is a variant of the original loki we're thinking
of the main loki that died during avengers
infinity war as the main loki so that's why you
see this version of loki walking around with a
time variance authority jacket that reads variant
on the back because he became a variant the minute
he stole the infinity stone and created all these
branch realities but when we see him in this clip
when they started is right after they've hauled
him through that trial with ravonna rennslayer the
person that Gugu Mbatha-Raw is playing she's just
referred to as judge rennslayer during this she's
like an administrator within the time variance
authority ruling over a lot of these judgments
but it seems that she's just booked him and
owen wilson's character mobius has had this
conversation with her you saw in that last big
clip i'll post a link to that in the description
below where he's basically trying to advocate
for loki like let's not erase him from existence
he might surprise us he might be able to fix this
situation her character has mostly shown up during
king the conqueror stories as his love interests
different alternate reality versions of her have
been with him at times she didn't work for the
time variance authority in the comics but there
was a version of kang the conqueror that became
immortus who essentially eventually just turned
over his entire empire to her because he got bored
with it there are many different versions of kang
the conqueror in the comics like you have the
scarlet centurion you have rama tut like the
original version that showed up in the fantastic
four comics the version of iron lad that shows
up in the young avengers stories is kind of
like the little kid version of kang immortus
is sort of like the last version of kang like
eventually in his distant future he turns into
a mortise and he was the one who worked with the
time keepers so i will explain a little bit more
about the time keepers in this video because loki
makes some jokes about them being space lizards
the reason why he calls them space lizards is
because they were actually created by he who
remains who was like the last person that worked
for the time variance authority or ruled over the
time variance authority at the end of time in
the last remaining reality of the multiverse
so it was like right before the heat death of
the very last universe in the entire multiverse
literally the end of time in that reality before
you went through another big bang cycle and
another firmament was created another version
of the multiverse was created we're going to
get super cosmic during marvel phase 4 because of
all this multiverse storytelling so they actually
get into that quite a bit during the ultimates
comics when they talk about galactus origin story
galactus isn't going to show up during the loki's
series but eventually we'll see him through those
new fantastic four movies that they're doing i'm
sure through the sequels like galactus is probably
going to be the next big avengers level event in
many many years but when you start getting into
the idea that multiverse you start dealing with
these big cosmic concepts it actually gets really
cool so there are actually a lot of marvel comics
that have covered this stuff that i'll point out
when these easter eggs show up but for those of
you that have been wanting to see more powerful
cosmic concepts inside the marvel cinematic
universe the timekeepers actually claim to be more
powerful than the living tribunal they present
themselves like they're helping keep control
of the timeline they're policing the timeline but
the way they portray them is kind of like the time
lords from doctor who and if you haven't watched
a bunch of doctor who doctor who is the main
character he's the protagonist the good person
who's supposed to be working amongst a bunch
of really bad bureaucrats so sometimes the time
lords themselves are portrayed as the villains
so we'll see if they wind up presenting the time
keepers in the same way like loki is joking about
how what they're doing is so absurd and they look
like space lizards because they are reptilian
that's why he's calling them space lizards and
even though he's kind of the antagonist in this
situation he's slowly becoming the hero on his
redemption arc i wouldn't be surprised if they go
the doctor who route because usually bureaucrats
in any big doctor whose story wind up being some
of the biggest villains like he talks about them
affecting the lives of trillions of people all
over the timeline but the actual place that
they're here their home base that exists at
the end of reality the end of the timeline
is literally called the citadel at the end
of time because it is literally at the end of
time it's mostly appeared during the classic
thor comics and as you can see they've just
read loki his riot act we're going to erase
you from existence because you're a trash variant
of the main loki and you just broke the timeline
in the whole reason why owen wilson's character
is kind of joking on him here like the reason why
he's not surprised by anything loki is doing is
because he's seen every single thing that has ever
happened in his life everything he's ever done
he's watched it kind of like a documentary movie
and that's basically where he's taking him in
this scene here like they're going up in the
elevator then walking through the hallway he's
taking him to this room that's called the time
theater to show him the movie that is his life
so to speak you see a little bit of that in the
other trailer footage but you have to remember
that this loki has just come from the end of the
first avengers movie so he never experienced
the events of thor the dark world or ragnarok
or avengers infinity war but the whole reason why
owen wilson's character mobius is trying to fight
for him so hard why he's giving him a chance is
because he's seen the main loki's timeline like
he's watched it all play out he saw him sacrifice
himself and become this good character redeem
himself so he's hoping that this version of loki
will surprise him the other big fantastic four
connection here is that agent mobius owen wilson's
character actually debuted during a time variance
authority storyline in the fantastic four comics
when they were trying to prosecute the fantastic
four for also messing with the timeline the way
that this version of loki messed with the timeline
that doesn't mean the fantastic four characters
are going to show up during the loki series
they're just playing out a lot of this energy sort
of world building so that eventually everything
connects down the road like you understand exactly
how kang the conqueror works as a character when
he shows up during ant-man and the wasp iii so
that when reed richards the other fantastic four
characters show up in the fantastic four movie
and start talking about the multiverse alternate
realities the negative zone it all makes sense
it's no coincidence that the fantastic four movie
is coming after doctor strange two multiverse of
madness a lot of you've also noticed the buttons
here in the elevator even though they go to
different floors here like this is a very complex
structure their time citadel here they'll just go
to very different places with different functions
within the time variance authority organization
one of the buttons that you don't see at least in
this thing you see it in one of the other scenes
is a button that looks like miss minutes this
small anthropomorphized clock that you see on all
these monitors the loki account was posting promos
for miss minutes a while ago people were just
wondering what this is supposed to mean because
of the way they present her in this other footage
when they're looking at the timeline itself like
there's a room here that looks like the bridge
of a starship where they're basically monitoring
the integrity of the timeline like owen wilson's
character is showing loki the actual breaks in the
timeline these are all these branch realities that
you created miss menace just seems like the hyper
advanced version of jarvis in the future that
the time variance authority might be using to
algorithmically monitor the integrity of the
timeline like miss minutes is part of the software
that they use to alert them when is going down in
someone like loki steals an infinity stone like
the tesseract the space stone it winds up creating
a bunch of branch timelines that they need to go
in and fix it does sound like loki knows at
least a little bit about the timekeepers like
he demonstrates that he is aware they exist like
thor odin the other asgardians the more long-lived
races in the galaxy the universe probably know
about the time keepers but the way he's acting
here just makes it sound like he's never actually
encountered a time variance authority person
and just thinks it all kind of ridiculous as he
read about it in stories also being really glib
like this is just one of his defense mechanisms
like he thinks that they're beneath him the same
way that he did during the first avengers movie
talking to the avengers like right now in his
head he's trying to formulate a plan to escape as
we see in some of the other trailer footage when
he's wearing that jacket so it seems like a lot of
the comedy especially in the earlier episodes like
right here at the beginning is him just failing
super hard at that because the time variance
authority is so advanced they've seen everything
that he's ever done so they know all of his tricks
so they're always literally and metaphorically
one step ahead of him it's not totally clear how
they're going to explain the way they manipulate
time travel some of the portals that they use here
look a little bit like quantum energy so they
might also be using the same quantum energy
that the avengers used during endgame to time
travel king the conqueror obviously big time
travel villain is showing up next during ant-man
3 quantum mania so because of the connection to
the quantum realm quantum energy the time variance
authority at least in the mcu might also just be
using quantum energy to do all this there's
only six episodes and they haven't said how
many different time periods they're going to if
it's going to be one per episode if there'll be
a bunch of different ones during the first couple
of episodes it also seems like female loki might
be the hooded figure you see running around in
these other scenes like she might be one of the
main antagonists of the series i don't know if
she's going to wind up being the main villain if
there'll be a big twist with that but it does seem
like they're fighting in a version of her citadel
whatever this is either it's like an alternate
reality version of asgard that's just really dark
like darkest timeline asgard or it's wherever her
home base winds up being they haven't confirmed
which other avengers characters are supposed to
show up during this but he does reference heimdall
and thor during the db cooper scene on the plane
before the bifrost catches him in midair and there
is a version of loki who winds up just landing
right in front of the rubble of the new york
city skyline like the avengers tower is broken
to pieces in the background there's also another
scene where it seems like they're reliving the
events of the first avengers movie so it'll be fun
to see which other events from the previous marvel
movies they also visit during the series tyga did
say that loki would show up during thor 4 love
and thunder in some way but he didn't say which
version of loki i'm assuming that because now
this variant tva version of loki is the main loki
it'll be this one but i don't know exactly what
he's supposed to be doing during that but they
did confirm that loki is getting season 2 so they
can't kill him off so whatever he's doing during
the events of thor love and thunder gore the god
butcher might not kill him off hard to say with
loki because he seemingly died many many times
but the whole idea is that each of the disney
plus series are supposed to set up and cross over
with future marvel movies like wandavision set up
doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness kind of
set up spiderman no way home falcon and winter
soldier was supposed to set up captain america 4
and thunderbolts so i'm mostly assuming that just
because of what the other directors have said so
far in the easter eggs we've seen in the trailers
that loki will help set up thor love and thunder
and maybe some of ant-man and the wasp iii with
king the conquerors character and maybe help tease
the fantastic four movie but they will also be
using the series to reference and do funny easter
eggs for a lot of the different earlier marvel
movies too so i'll point those out when we see
them in episodes loki in general is meant to be
a bigger foray into the concept of the multiverse
in the mcu exploring these alternate realities
which is why they're releasing the loki episodes
before the marvel what if episodes we actually
just found out those episodes are going to start
in august probably after the olympics i just did
a video about the multiverse avengers team that
the watcher is assembling from alternate realities
during that so i'll post a link at the end of this
there was also a new black widow trailer that they
released so i'll do a video for that next and then
there's a new snake eyes trailer that i'll try to
do a video for tomorrow so whole bunch of trailer
footage whole bunch of stuff happening this week
make sure you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss any of those videos and i'll
name a giveaway winner in that black widow trailer
video when i post that later tonight while you
wait for everything click here for my brand new
thor 4 love and thunder first look video and click
here for that brand new marvel what if trailer
and learn about that multiverse avengers team
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!